[Music]
on this Wednesday night how Democrats in
the U.S defied expectations definitely
not a republican way that's for darn
sure what motivated voters in the
midterms plus the biggest losers and
winners Florida is where wolf goes to
die what it all means for 2024 and I
talked to Canada's Ambassador in
Washington about the health of American
democracy meta layoffs what massive job
Cuts could mean for a Global Tech Giant
and the industry
plus where did it come from why was it
so important the mystery surrounding a
wartime Relic featured at this year's
Remembrance Day
global national with Donna frasen
reporting tonight from Washington
good evening and thanks for joining us
the American midterm elections which
were expected to give a boost to
Republican fortunes have defied
historical odds and exceeded the
expectations of opinion polls and
pundits some of the votes are still
being counted but Democrats could keep
control of the Senate though are looking
likely to lose their majority in the
House of Representatives historically
the party that holds the White House
does badly in the midterms that didn't
happen this time and today President Joe
Biden is sounding buoyant
I am so optimistic about the prospects
for America
we need to be looking to the Future the
fact that the Democratic party
outperformed anything anyone expected
and did better than any off-year
presidency since John Kennedy is one
that gives everybody like whoo
sigh relief that the mega Republicans
are not taking over
Jackson prosco our Washington bureau
chief is with me at Jackson he certainly
sounded relieved and and buoyant as I
said with these results what do you
think the results mean for Biden himself
and for the country you know it seems
that overwhelmingly Americans decided
they were in favor of the party of Biden
and not the party of trump and I think
in doing so they're sending a strong
message about the type of values they're
willing to accept for the country and
perhaps they bought some breathing room
for American democracy
thank you
it was a night of big wins for Democrats
and tonight that's why
[Music]
and clear upsets for Republicans as
Stark candidates like Dr menados were
soundly defeated
others like Herschel Walker now languish
in races too close to call if you can
hang in hang in there a little bit
longer the unpopularity of President Joe
Biden a faltering economy and record
high inflation did not sway voters
definitely not a republican wave that's
for darn sure
everybody
but the man not on the ballot former
president Donald Trump played a huge
role we have uh some races that are hot
and heavy and we're all watching them
here Trump's hand-picked candidates were
more often than not defeated most had
backed his election fraud lies if I was
a republican I would absolutely uh
distance myself from Trump the Trump
candidates are top to bottom have done
far far more poorly than the the more
independent ones
that strategy worked for Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis who won
re-election in a landslide we not only
won election we have Rewritten the
political map while New York wants a
stronghold for Democrats became a
surprising Battleground elsewhere the
party's one-time stars like Beto
O'Rourke in Texas and Stacy Abrams in
Georgia failed to break through
[Applause]
yet Democrats remain buoyed by broad
successes across the board Michigan's
Democratic governor Gretchen Whitmer
cruised to re-election her party swept
the state house and voters backed a
referendum protecting abortion rights we
are feeling damn good about where we are
headed a remarkable night for a party
that wasn't expecting much to celebrate
not just voters in Michigan upholding
abortion access rights they did it in
Kansas too this is a sign that this was
at the end of the day a major motivating
factor for voters especially young ones
who turned out in droves at the end of
the day Donna very hard for a lot of
women especially to separate the loss of
Rights and the economic argument in many
ways they're intertwined definitely and
Jackson in the final days of the
campaign we kept hearing President Biden
Hammer home the message that democracy
was on the line in this vote there were
a lot of people including some Democrats
who said that was the wrong tact to take
the wrong message do we have any way to
measure if it had an impact you know at
the end of the day actually does seem
likely that it did have an impact and I
think the reason we can say that is
because it brought out those young
voters who were deeply concerned about
the future but also the vast majority of
those election denying Republican
candidates who are on the ballot for
positions that actually have oversight
of Elections they've lost they are not
winning their elections by running on an
anti-democratic Grant all right Jackson
Brosco thank you well one man who has
emerged as a threat to former president
Donald Trump's apparent intention to run
for office again is Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis he won easily last night some
Republican strategists are already
calling him the front runner and
President Biden said tonight he looks
forward to watching Trump and DeSantis
take each other on Eric Sorensen looks
at what's shaping up for the 2024
presidential campaign
we will never ever surrender to the woke
mob almost overnight Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis has become a national
political force and Donald Trump's New
Nightmare and I have only begun to fight
Trump has already given DeSantis a
nickname there it is Trump at 71 Rhonda
sanctimonious at 10 a Telltale sign that
Trump sees a threat for the Republican
Presidential nomination Trump quoted
online that DeSantis could hurt himself
badly I would tell you things about him
that won't be very flattering he's not
spend the next few months talking about
Joe Biden nearly as much
as a threat to him DeSantis has already
created a national presence sparking
protests with a bill that prohibits
classroom instruction to young children
on sexual orientation and gender
identity he infuriated many when he had
migrants flown to Massachusetts a
democratic Run State and that's what
Biden's doing he created the Border
crisis he has targeted the U.S president
and is popular enough to campaign for
other Republicans outside Florida are
you ready to save New York State Trump
meantime looks vulnerable after hedging
his bets in the midterms last night on
news Nation if they win I should get all
the credit and if they lose I should not
be blamed at all but key candidates that
Trump supported lost and some
Republicans do blame him a lot of
Republicans lost or shouldn't have been
running to begin with and I think this
hurts Trump fundamentally I I would be
very surprised if Trump were the
Republican nominee in 2024. this ain't
your father's Republican party President
Joe Biden may be itching to run against
any Republican but he's almost 80 and
many in his own party quietly expect or
hope he won't run again
going to run for president again about
you know six months that has to be known
he has to he has to let other people
know to line up for further for other
candidates Democrats may offer Biden the
courtesy of waiting for him to decide
for Trump and the Republicans and I'm
gonna try to bring the Trump
organization to Palm Beach past
alliances could quickly turn nasty if
DeSantis throws his hat in the ring Eric
Sorensen Global News
to Canadian news Alberta Premier
Danielle Smith now has a seat in the
legislature after winning a by-election
make no mistake from what you saw from
the results today we certainly have a
fight ahead of us
turnout was low Smith won just under 55
percent of the votes cast She's admitted
that was not the decisive mandate she
was looking for albertans are set to go
to the polls in a general election on
May 29th to the emergencies act inquiry
in Ottawa now the mayor of Coots Alberta
says his community is still divided
since a protest blockade formed in his
Border Town in February testifying today
Jim Willett said he spoke out against
border vaccine mandates as mayor but
once the blockade began it lost his
support
you stand there with your foot on my
throat and say
you're not going to go through here
anymore and what you're doing is you're
actually choking the uh the livelihood
of the lawyer
your friends and Neighbors
Ontario's Deputy solicitor general also
took the stand today his testimony was
cut short though when the lawyer
questioning him collapsed that lawyer
was taken to the hospital and is
expected to be okay
there is a fresh focus on Canada's
relationship with China from both sides
of the political Spectrum following
Global's exclusive reporting earlier
this week about alleged Chinese
interference in the 2019 federal
election campaign today during his first
media availability in nearly two months
conservative leader Pierre poliov called
for a parliamentary committee
investigation
I think it's very troubling that the
Prime Minister has known about
allegations of foreign interference in
Canadian elections since last January
and he hasn't take any action I haven't
seen any evidence of action from this
government to protect our democracy from
that kind of foreign interference
prime minister Justin Trudeau is heading
to Asia for a series of summits next
week our new Ottawa reporter Mackenzie
gray explains what the government is
signaling about its approach to China
a new approach from the federal
government on relations with a growing
superpower the China of 1970 is not the
China of today
China is an increasingly disruptive
Global power the stern warning from
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
signals A New Path for the Liberals
indo-pacific strategy in a wide-ranging
speech Jolie vowed Canada would confront
China on their treatment of the uyghur
population defend territorial rights of
Hong Kong and Taiwan and caution
Canadian businesses operating in China
the decision you take as business people
are your own
as Canada's top Diplomat my job is to
tell you that there are geopolitical
risks linked to doing business with the
country to lessen those geopolitical
risks the Liberals want businesses to
diversify their trade and deepen
relations with India and other friendly
nations in Asia the indo-pacific market
is all about relationships and
businesses about relationships we need
to be present we need to be there the
more confrontational approach makes a
major reversal for Jolie who didn't even
mention China in the government's first
draft of their indo-pacific strategy the
message of China should be simple we
have no problem with you being a
superpower you have to stop acting as a
bully and you have to respect
international law but it's Canadian
election law that China is alleged to
have broken sources tell Global News
Chinese agents allegedly infiltrated the
offices of sitting members of parliament
and spent nearly a quarter million
dollars finding a secret network of at
least 11 candidates who ran both for the
Liberals and conservatives in the 2019
teen general election
for Justin Trudeau's former Foreign
Affairs advisor the alleged interference
underscores the need for the government
to act on China it's a very encouraging
outline but in my line of business at
least you don't get grades for an
outline you get it for the essay the
Liberals will get to test out their new
China strategy in the coming days as the
Prime Minister set to travel tomorrow to
multiple International Summits in Asia
including the G20 Donna
Mackenzie Ray in Ottawa thanks
major layoffs at a Global Tech Giant
coming up what job cuts that meta signal
for the tech sector
foreign
of mass layoffs is never good news for
any company and today meta the parent
company of Facebook Instagram and
WhatsApp announced it is cutting its
Workforce by 13 that adds up to 11 000
employees as Ann gaviola explains it's
just the latest wave of economic woes
that have been slamming the tech
industry recently
the social media giant has never axed
jobs on this scale before met a CEO and
Facebook founder Mark Zuckerberg offered
a Mia culpa The macroeconomic downturn
increased competition and add signal
loss caused our Revenue to be much lower
than expected he said in a statement I
got this wrong meta sank billions into
the so-called metaverse but lost sight
of its other platforms including
Instagram and Facebook the cuts will be
across the board with a big blow to the
recruiting team as the company reduces
headcount and real estate footprint to
slash costs Global News reached out but
the company wouldn't say how many
Canadian jobs have been cut layoffs and
about face from March when the company
was set to higher 2500 people in Canada
it's an illustration of just how quickly
things can change in technology that you
think that you're going into a fast
growth period you're you're all
optimistic you're making all sorts of
Rosy announcements and then just a few
months later the economic wins tend to
change direction terminations and hiring
freezes have been the trend among the
biggest names in Tech in recent months
including ottawa-based e-commerce giant
Shopify chipmaker Intel and Twitter
under Elon musk's ownership and Tech is
seen as a Bellwether for the broader
economy and as a result as technology
starts to retrench in his big tech
companies start to resize themselves for
this new reality other sectors should be
watching and paying attention the tech
surge reflected in soaring stock prices
and hiring binges is over now there's a
potential recession set to follow the
current pullback in spending on ads and
technology and gaviola Global News
Toronto
now to the war in Ukraine Russia's
defense minister has ordered troops to
retreat from cursam the only Ukrainian
Regional Capital captured by Russia the
defense minister says it's no longer
possible to supply the city or Russian
troops so they're being pulled back to
the East Bank of the nipro river over
the past few weeks the Russians have
also relocated more than one hundred
thousand people from the city The
Retreat appears to be a serious setback
but Ukraine fears it could be part of a
wider strategy or a trap
ahead I speak with Canada's ambassador
to the U.S and get her perspective on
the help of our closest neighbors
democracy
people have said to me why do you have
to cover the U.S midterm elections well
here's why the U.S is not only Canada's
closest neighbor we share the world's
longest international border we have 120
land ports of Entry nearly 2.6 billion
dollars in goods and services are traded
between the U.S and us every day that
plus all the cultural and the family
ties is why we pay such close attention
to this place earlier today I spoke with
someone whose job is to manage the
relationship Canada's ambassador to the
United States
thank you so much for joining us today
it's a delight to be here thank you you
know Canadians watch the United States
closely certainly whenever there's an
election and in this election cycle
particularly because of the polarization
and the political violence what's your
takeaway from these midterms
well you know I actually would like to
say that I think that yesterday was a
really good day for a U.S Democratic
process it was very high voter turnout
both in advance and on Election Day uh
there it was a safe and orderly election
it's not to say that there weren't a few
incidents here and there there were but
by and large uh it was it was a very
safe and orderly election with a big
voter turnout there's still more votes
to be counted but I do think especially
given as you say that there was concern
around safety and around security the
fact that it was so normal and so well
attended is a real vote of confidence
for the U.S system President Biden and
former president Obama were both
campaigning in the final days saying
that democracy was on the ballot in
these midterms are you confident that
the guard rails in place are strong
enough in this country to protect
democracy
I am but I do believe that Americans
need to keep paying attention to those
guard rails they need to be paying
attention to their democracy and
fighting for it and I think they are
fighting for it I think the reason that
we are hearing so much about it is
because they care so much about it
um you know it's it's true that the
rhetoric around political discourse
sometimes the tone and tenor is is
divisive is is is disrespectful but
that's not just true in the United
States that's true in in a lot of
countries it's true in our country from
time to time and I think we need to pay
attention to that since you mentioned
President Obama one of one of the things
that he used to say is that it's
important to learn how to disagree
without being disagreeable that's
probably something we should all think
about let me ask you about the trusted
traveler program the Nexus program
it's still not fixed right I think
there's a backlog about half a million
Canadians who are waiting for for Nexus
it's about 350 000. okay
waiting a while and I understand that
there's still the the issue is not
resolved the Canadian Chamber of
Commerce I think is worried that the
program might be ended is that the
outcome here no it's not the outcome and
actually just at the end of last week at
the beginning of this week Minister
Mendocino spoke twice with secretary
mayorkas I have been speaking with the
most senior officials in the Department
of Homeland Security about the program
and I think there's really two things to
say most important the U.S has
recommitted time and time again to the
program and said we want it to they want
it to succeed they want it to continue
I'm not worried it takes time it is it's
frustrating for those that are waiting
including people you know in in at the
embassy and in my family and I'm sure
all of our families but we'll get there
all right Ambassador thank you my
pleasure thank you
a relic of Canada's past next why a
mysterious flag found at the app will be
displayed in Ottawa
during the national ceremony in Ottawa
this Remembrance Day a flag that's at
the center of a multi-decade mystery
will be on display it's believed it was
carried during the diep raid in northern
France what became Canada's deadliest
day of the second world war and as Mike
Armstrong reports the riddle of the
flag's Origins makes it all the more
fascinating
it is one flag with two stories one
fascinating the other a mystery we'll
start with what is known and who it
belonged to last I wish dad would be
here I think he'd be I think he'd be
overwhelmed Mike Lowry of Lexington
Virginia donated the flag to the Royal
Canadian Legion he says his father
Charles got it from a friend in 1965 an
American Veteran from the second world
war who had guarded German prisoners
that veteran apparently found the flag
on a pow a German who said he'd been in
Die app for Canada's failed raid in 1942
he'd been burying bodies and took it off
a Canadian who'd been killed the
American Soldier took it the friend told
Dad that they planned to give it to a
Canadian unit when they ran across one
but unfortunately they never ran across
one so that's the story that's known but
there's a twist it is a Canadian flag
but it wasn't Canada's flag at the time
of the deep raid it's much older The
Shield at the bottom right includes a
charging Buffalo representing Manitoba
but nothing for BC well those provinces
joined Canada barely a year apart that
means this was Canada's flag in 1870 and
1871. it predates the diep raid by more
than seven decades I was shocked that a
flag that's so old would be in such good
shape
I'd say it's priceless
now that brings us to the unknown why
would a 70 year old flag be at the app
it's a fantastic mystery military
historian David O'Keefe says it could
have been a soldier's family heirloom
something passed on possibly from a
father to a son for good luck but there
are more questions he says than answers
where did it come from why was it so
important why was it considered if it
was a good luck charm why was it
considered that way
during this year's National Remembrance
Day service the flag will be displayed
in front of the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier a symbol of the sacrifice at
diap for this 80th anniversary he
probably wouldn't believe it Mike Lowry
says for decades his late father always
wanted to give the flag to a Canadian
family or a regiment instead he says it
feels like he gave it to the entire
country Mike Armstrong Global News
Ottawa
we will have live coverage of this
year's Remembrance Day ceremony in
Ottawa at 10 30 a.m Eastern 7 30 Pacific
right here on global and on our website
globalnews.ca
that is global national for this
Wednesday from the American Capital I'm
Donna Friesen thanks for watching for
now good night
[Music]